avengers assemble for the first and
final lines of your favorite mcu
characters how do we do this as a team
the first three phases of the marvel's
cinematic universe gave fans some of the
most memorable heroes and villains in
movie history let's find out how these
super characters change between their
first lines and their last ones i feel
like you're driving me to court-martial
this is crazy what did i do there is
arguably no character arc in the mcu
better than tony starks aka iron man
made clear by his first line where he
makes things completely about himself
the billionaire playboy philanthropist
started out as a selfish warmonger
before getting blasted by his own weapon
and starting his transformation into a
selfless peacemaker iron man charmed us
with his trademark humor from the
beginning but he left us with a truly
heartfelt final goodbye
i love you three thousand
going by the alias natalya rushman black
widow snuck into the mcu posing as a
simple notary in iron man 2. i
need you to initially spawn
but by the end of the film everyone knew
she was a force to be reckoned with
natasha romanov's checkered past left
her guilt-ridden and striving for
redemption so when her journey from a
deceptive spy to a trustworthy hero
ended with the ultimate sacrifice she
made it clear the choice was hers
[Music]
kind of makes you think twice about
enlisting huh
nope
based on those first words one thing is
very clear about steve rogers he is not
easily discouraged the first captain
america went through a number of
physical transformations from a scrawny
young man who refused to give up to an
old man that went and got some of that
life tony stark was talking about the
one thing that didn't change was his
heart funny enough cap's first and last
lines were a happy refusal
no
no i don't think i will one of loki's
best tricks was his very first line in
the mcu and he didn't even realize it
do the frost giants still live
the god of mischief's first words
actually spoke to his true origin as the
son of laufey leader of the enemy frost
giants loki's final line came right
before his end at the hands of thanos
defying the evil tyrant with one last
taunt
lucky for us we've still got his variant
when i'm king
i'll hunt the monsters down and slay
them all
thor's first line comes right after
loki's highlighting his brutish and
self-serious nature but the god of
thunder's obsession with power glory and
title eventually faded hardships and
great loss forced him to grow and
changed him into a hilarious former king
of asgard who willingly walked away from
his throne he joined up with the
guardians of the galaxy and left us with
these very sarcastic words after
star-lord claims he's in charge
of course
of course
of course
the hulk's first words might sound a
little weird to fans and it's not just
because the big dream guy didn't say
that is he ready
before mark ruffalo took on the role of
dr bruce banner in the avengers movie
actor edward norton was the first man to
go green in the mcu but in the end it is
smart hulk who delivers the last line
well get him back i'm trying get him to
hell back yeah try to try
black panther's first and last lines do
an amazing job of tracking the
characters immense growth throughout the
mcu i suppose neither of us is used to
the spotlight
fans first meet t'challa as a prince not
yet ready to stand in the spotlight
after he officially takes on the mantle
of the black panther the king of wakanda
rose to the occasion no longer afraid to
take center stage his final words
reflect that as he takes the gauntlet
from hawkeye during the final battle and
end game great
[Music]
give it to me when it comes to the
original avengers hawkeye is in a
slightly different tier compared to his
super powered counterparts and that's
clear in his first line in thor
you want me to slow him down sir or are
you sending in more guys for him to beat
up hawkeye can usually be found just
left of center throughout the marvel
films but he's also been present at the
most critical moments and battles just
like his first line his last also has
him talking about another avenger once
again highlighting how his regular
position is just outside the spotlight
we did it
wanda maximoff's journey began in battle
with the avengers alongside the evil
artificial intelligence ultron
talk and if you're wasting our time
after breaking free of ultron's
manipulation and losing her twin brother
pietro her brief but passionate love
affair with vision only brought her more
pain and suffering but wanda rose above
it all stronger than ever and in one
division her final lines assure us that
she'll return better than ever
goodbye monica
super ai vision came into the world a
virtual baby fully grown with red skin
and an infinity stone in his forehead
his first words perfectly encapsulate
just how bizarre that all is i'm sorry
that was
odd
shortly after meeting and falling for
wanda maximoff he met his demise at her
very hands and then thanos's only to be
mysteriously resurrected in wandevision
but by the end the two were forced to
part yet again something tells me this
isn't the last we've seen a vision
protecting the universe from tyranny is
probably a 24-hour job so captain
marvel's first lines in the mcu is
pretty fitting do you know what time it
is
can't sleep arguably the strongest
avenger carol danvers didn't return to
the fold until things were more dire
than they'd ever been after saving
tony's life at the start of end game she
came back yet again and turned the tide
in the final battle her last line in
phase 3 hints at her and spider-man's
future roles at the center of the mcu
hey peter parker you got something for
me scott lang is introduced to the
marvel universe on his last day in jail
where he plans to leave his life of
crime behind
[Applause]
he didn't even move
but it isn't long before he's swiping a
certain hank pym super suit and becoming
the next ant-man although he is
definitely a hero lang's criminal pass
proves too useful to truly leave behind
and the proof is in his final line in
endgame
what it's dead
i have to hotwire it
this isn't your friendly neighborhood
spider-man's first time on the big
screen not even close so peter parker's
first line in the mcu wastes no time
reintroducing us to a familiar character
hey mate
with spider-man set to be at the heart
of phase four his final line in
spider-man far from home tees us up for
a wild story
[Music]
parker's last words also have quite a
bit in common with his ants at the end
of spider-man homecoming
the man that started it all nick fury's
first line was actually originally said
by another member of the avengers
i am iron man
the shield commander and founder of the
avengers has been present from the very
beginning leading with his trademark
no-nonsense attitude but at the end of
phase 3 he appears to have mellowed a
bit as he shifts his focus to an
entirely new mission
nebula's journey began in servitude to
ronan the conqueror
ronan
has returned her cold and rigid
personality made her a loyal and violent
follower but the influence of her sister
gamora and tony stark miraculously
transformed her into a sarcastic
laid-back member of the guardians the
proof of her newfound attitude is clear
in her final line in endgame you should
fight one another for the honor of
leadership sounds fair
rocket the talking super genius space
raccoon had some pretty abrasive first
words xandarians
what a bunch of losers
that's a lot of disdain for people that
he would actually save by the end of the
film that kind of contradiction is at
the heart of rocket whose last lines of
phase 3 is full of delight as he adds
more fuel to the conflict between his
comrades thor and star lord i got some
blasters unless you guys want to use
knives dr stephen strange's know-it-all
personality was present long before he
was the powerful sorcerer supreme as
evidenced by his introduction where
strange shows off his vast musical
knowledge
challenge round billy when hubris takes
away his prized hands and starts him
down his path of magic he becomes a
little less narcissistic and
self-centered along the way but his last
line in endgame makes it clear the
know-it-all personality is still there
if i tell you what happens
it won't happen star-lord brash leader
of the guardians of the galaxy had an
unexpectedly sweet introduction to the
mcu
they killed a little frog that ain't
done nothing
thanks to his tumultuous time in space
the once pure-hearted kid who defended
the defenseless became an insecure
narcissistic adult who still defends the
defenseless on occasion for a reward his
insecurity shines through in his final
phase three line
me
marvel big bad thanos's first line
accurately highlighted his arrogance
constantly looking down on everyone
around him the only matter i do not take
seriously boy
is you on his insane mission to collect
all the infinity stones and eliminate
half of all life in the universe the mad
titan drew the ire of every avenger
thanos's final words tie back perfectly
to his first line demonstrating his
hubris as his arrogance sealed his fate
i am
inevitable
much like hulk war machine aka colonel
james rhodes saw a bit of recasting
going from terence howard to don cheadle
as liaison to stark industries
cheeto takes over from iron man 2 on
delivering a bit of a pump fake for the
character's final line in end game
see you on the other side
fortunately in this case the other side
meant the falcon and the winter soldier
it's a new day brother
with phase 4 just getting started
characters like loki wanda maximoff
captain marvel and spiderman have many
more iconic lines in store for the
coming films and tv shows what's your
favorite mcu quote so far which phase
four character will be the first to
speak their final line let us know in
the comments